we played a sound bite of bill belichick
being asked if stefan gilman was there
and he said well we haven't checked in
yet we don't
we don't know i think he was talking
about the weather was bad people were
either
in or not they didn't know uh but there
was one intrepid reporter
uh who refused to let that stand uh a
follow-up question had to be asked
and that was uh uh by tom curran give a
listen you
you understand how the operation works
we don't see people out there mandatory
mini camp are you saying let's not
go over the barricades here if there's a
it's not that big a deal
in other words
no i'm saying today's the first day they
just got in here a little while ago
uh i'm not sure if everybody
is here we didn't take attendance
at the meeting but we'll find out
you know who's here and who isn't soon
enough
thank you that includes the players that
were here last week and the players that
weren't here last week and everything
else
all right so let's take attendance chris
brockman are you here present
uh tj jefferson are you here are you
here
okay uh mike del tufore here uh tom
curran are you here
yo
i'll take that as a present tom take
this present
this was uh as it turns out no stephon
gilmour today also no chase one of its
nor byron cowart
so there were three absences uh gilmore
being the most noteworthy rich because
you know he is paid seven and a half
million and the best guys
position are making close to eighteen
and steph has averaged fourteen million
over the course of his contract last
year the contract 31 years old porn quad
what's more door what are we going to do
why aren't the other guys there tom
weather huh so i mean that that that was
to me
and you know bill very well yes no bill
very well we've
both observed him for a long time to
make it sound like
the patriots are the suddenly the kid
running down this
driveway with his book bag open and
chewing on a doughnut
and heading for the bus at the beginning
of many campus
is a huge stretch they're very organized
they know everybody is there
i mean malcolm butler showed up late
because his flight was delayed for otas
in 2015 and they didn't put him on the
field for three weeks and that was
after the super bowl pick
it's okay though okay so uh
do it do we get over the barricades to
use your phrase here or
i just think that our ears perk up and
we peek over them
see what's going on and to me
when we look at this i think bill saying
that
is an indication that he doesn't really
feel like ratcheting things up at the
moment
he understands what steps great is but
he again is coming off a torn quad that
cost in the last five games of the
season he had surgery
before he gets any kind of a bump and he
did get a bump last year
he's gonna need to show up and show that
he can run on it and if he wants an
extension
he's definitely gonna need to show up
and show that um
he wants to be here is my definitive
understanding
stronger does not want to leave the
patriots so i would call it uh
can we say impasse instead of
loggerheads yes we can
we can use whatever phrase you'd like
but loggerheads no but
you've you you know again we're at that
part of uh
uh of the nfl you know year and season
where it's like is this uh
real or not you know and you know and
and even cam's injury from a couple
weeks ago is this real or not
and no i don't say that that he was
faking what i mean like is this
significant
enough to affect something that happens
in the fall or not and it looks like
that's the
or not that he's backing he didn't have
a great practice today rainy day out
here
in uh new england rainy in boston and he
labored a bit he was the least accurate
of the three who didn't throw much so
mac jones had a good practice and um
the student was pretty accurate and cam
you know was a little bit erratic to the
point where he was frustrated and kind
of thrown off the side now is that
rain is that thumb is that just
cam hard to say but we're going to enter
a period of time over the next two days
with this mini camp we're
kind of watching how he throws because
he this is a
legitimate competition houses
walk me through what the competition is
i mean what what what does it really
look like or when you say competition
that that it could be
stidham's gig like week one they they
they resign cam and they
they uh draft a quarterback in the first
round for the first time since
bledsoe and it could wind up being jared
stidham anyway literally another guy
lawyer no the other guy who's the other
guy
matt jones
they are a gog
i used a gog and loggerheads um they are
a gog
why what do you mean he's just
the word is the the senses that he is
further along
than any rookie quarterback they've had
pass to the system period
since two thousand he just gets what
he's expected to do
and because he's shown this ability
and the aptitude they are putting a lot
on them already
in the passing campaign in the mini camp
they want to see how much he can handle
so that when training camp begins it can
be
a competition bill loves kim newton
and i think that matt jones has to win
by knockout over everybody he has to
knock out
stim it has to be clear and he would
have to knock out cam
and cam would have to be an impediment
to the offense
working well but matt jones has
not the door wide open but it sure isn't
slam shut on them
well look tom i mean we know the stories
you you you you know them
as well as anybody that when brady came
trotting out on the field after mo lewis
blew up bledsoe
that you know we were all saying well
that's the end of that but
many in new england were like well here
comes a kid who had a better summer than
anybody else
and and and and so i i totally
um believe that um but the
the reason why i kept on going to
everybody but mac jones is that
you know um is this really going to be
belichick's umpteenth season
and he's just going to start the the
rookie and do the
the just like what everybody else is the
the the ups and downs
uh with a rookie quarterback which we're
assuming it's gonna be because
the brady stuff only happens once in a
lifetime but of course it would be very
belichick in new england if it's the
second one
but walk me through that yeah
one awesome quote from that week
after brady leapfrog damon heward to
become number two during
training camp right was belichick
standing up and there was some report to
say how come
you're not going to go to keyword here
it's got more experience you spent three
million dollars to sign them as a backup
and belt except look i just don't think
i'm going to be standing here
every single week talking about all the
things that tom brady did wrong
and that i that stuck with me forever
because it wasn't about
she's going to rip it up he's going to
do things about so can't was just look
he's not going to poop his pants out
there
and if matt jones can show that aptitude
i think it's still a less than twenty
percent chance probably less than
fifteen percent chance that he's
starting the opener
believe me i'm not trying to overstate
it i'm just saying there
is going to be competition
it's not an anointment the way bill has
kind of indicated
and i think that the reason he keeps
saying kim's a starter
is because he understands as a question
as to whether or not cam can be the
starter because there are limitations to
what he can do
in the passing game no i i i
i love this this is so fascinating if
this gets if this kid starts the first
game
it's a complete rewind to 20 years ago
this is the greatest
beat in professional sports history
it really is amazing and just having a
front row seat of seeing belichick
at a you know the crossroads is a stupid
word for it
but i i i i don't know what is the word
for it
it could be a reboot what's the word for
autumn yeah the reboot the autumn i mean
i've i've called it looking at 1.0
dynasty oh
2000 to 2009 he had a 2.0 dynasty 2010
to 2019 and really this is a 3.0 can you
reboot it again you're
you're exactly right well because we've
not seen new england with a first-round
drafted quarterback
coming off of a free agency season in
which they spent 160
million dollars in ownership of a third
place schedule
i mean it's it really is something we
have not seen
uh in the belichick era in new england
and just seeing does it seem to me again
he does seem you know i know he probably
would blanch the word revitalized but
this this does seem to have energized
him you know he's into it i think
right i think there was a fatigue with
the brady and gronkowski thing
and look bill was spending second round
picks on muhammad sanu
just to make sure you could milk
everything he was putting up with
josh gordon antonio brown and going
ownership and dealing with all that
stuff
because you just had to milk that cow as
long as you could
and the house on it was a beautiful cow
elsewhere other people are getting the
milk but now he's got a new cow
these others are fresh
there is there's a lot to it that
you know it's different it's new
his kids are with them um
he set for life in terms of his legacy
and what he's doing
so i'm not saying he's doing it for you
know poops and giggles but
the heat is not necessarily on
tom curran of nbc sports boston few more
minutes left with the uh patriots
insider as the patriots hold their
mandatory minicamp
what happened with them and julio jones
because that would have put him
we would be having i think a even more
different conversation
if he did cough up the two for sunu uh
and i understand that that was a totally
different
set of circumstances with brady in a
remaining
window of opportunity why not this time
around for
either cam or his kid that he might
start week one based on what you're
saying you're seeing
uh or what they're seeing out of mac
jones so far first blush
what happened with julio it's gonna be
the fifteen point three the fact that
tennessee was willing to pay full
freight and then they've now
mortgaged a little bit by having penny
he'll redo his deal so he's got a forty
one million dollar cap if i'm not
mistaken
so that's the kind of chaos that that
invites and i think that bill
got out of that particular frying pan
even though he spent all this money
patriots still have like 16 million
dollars in cap space
um and they're not going to be in a bad
place even though they spent all the
money that they have they're not going
to be in a bad place in the next couple
years
inviting in a 31 year old wide receiver
who be making 15.3 which is
you know and you already have steph
gilmore
with a cap at a sixteen and dante
hightower the captain at twelve
and he'd be like well what are we doing
so i think
if they weren't asking for someone to
take full freight atlanta
and night the entire contract maybe the
patriots would employers but i think
that everybody kinda
backed off for that week except for
tennessee
so before i let you go and then we'll
catch up during the summer tom
what what is the real real expectation
what what do you got for me like what
because this this this team could win a
division if they get the right
quarterback play i mean because the
defense seems to be
young and doing their job and knowing
how to do your job
right like that that that it's that side
of the the ball that they
in terms of remaking and retooling that
they have to worry about the least
i would say how how real with the the
bills now sitting
uh astride this division with a a studly
quarterback like
josh allen what do you got for me on
that front the patriots might have had
anywhere between the 29th and 32nd most
talented rosters in the nfl last year
they still won seven games
they had no tight end when i mean don't
know tight ends they had no tight ends
to throw to
their wide receivers is not a team in
football who especially one settlement
got hurt
that would have said we'll take those
guys any of those guys
so they've now brought into the top ten
tight ends
they brought in capable wide receivers
they've got a rookie quarterback they
have trent brownback to play tackle
um they've improved matthew jude on not
the high towers come back
kyle duggar is going to be a pro bowler
at least you have
if gilmore comes back and you have henry
anderson up front i mean it's just a
stacked
their team so this is a weather twin
team i think
rich and i had them at eight and eight
last year
[Music]
they're good they're gonna be good can
we good what do you got for me before
you want to leave uh brockman you want
to ask a question yeah tom i just want
to ask you like from a fan's perspective
if bill likes mac jones as well as it
seems like he does
right why not just cut cam now and like
hand the brains over to the guy
it's a great question he he likes him
but i think he
loves cam because cam is actually in
many ways representative of what bill
wants from patriots players
believe it or not he is eating the
financial poop sandwich with no bread
that's my third poop reference
with no bread throughout this if he's
making five billion dollars he is
showing up for everything he is doing
everything the bill asks
and that's a great example additionally
i think that the chemistry in the karma
of the team karma not right but
just the overall chemistry of the team
these guys really are gravitating to cam
even though he is limited so i think
don't want
to let it play out and he wants to give
himself a fall back because
even if mac jones isn't ready the one
thing kim can do
is he can even things up because you
play eleven on eleven with a running
quarterback
so no reason to to to push all your
chips onto the
the mac jones number right now but isn't
mac jones operating a different offense
we
i guess the more typical brady run uh
mcdaniel's offense then
yeah we'll definitely have to see in
camp what kind of stuff they're running
but i cannot imagine there's going to be
many you know read options
that that matt jones is running although
cam didn't do a lot of it either matt
jones did do
some of that at alabama so that's gonna
have to be
t v d um but
there is a different way of of coaching
that and bill talked about that a lot
back in
you know two thousand michael bishop was
here and and you know you have to split
the rep so that everybody's getting
stuff that makes them good
and prepared so it's absolutely worth
watching but but it is too early to go
up and off cam
all right tom thanks for the call man
really appreciate it have a great summer
you got it that's time
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here